- [Deepali] Alright, so let
me start with a statement
which is older application
or legacy applications are reliable.
100%. No doubt in that, right?
But when it comes to the
adaptation or automation,
it becomes a little bit tricky
with the legacy application
and it becomes really
tough when you are new
to that application,
you do not understand the code base
and you want to modernize it,
but you're still figuring
it out how it works, right?
So if I tell you that you
can create an AI agent
who will interact with that
legacy system and can act
and think on its own
without rewriting anything,
that would be pretty awesome, right?
That will make our life
a little bit easier
as a developer or architect,
something like that.
So well, to show you
exactly how to do that,
I am Deepali Talande,
along with my colleagues Franz Stefan,
and Jan Thewes,
together we will demonstrate how to use
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore to create
that agentic AI into the
existing legacy application.
Okay, so before we dive in,
I know we all are here to
see us coding, you know,
troubleshooting online,
everything like that.
But give me few minutes to
go through the core concepts
so that it is easy for all of
us to follow what we are doing
and why we are doing it.
And after that, Franz is gonna take over
and he's gonna start by
showing you how easy it is
to create an AI agent using Strands SDK,
and run it on AgentCore runtime,
all in an empty project.
And after that, Jan is gonna show you
how to do the same thing
within an existing legacy system.
Okay, so let's start by understanding
the agentic loop itself
or how the LLMs work on a very high level.
So you begin with a prompt
that you provide to the agent
and which could be something like,
what's the weather in London today?
This will basically
trigger the initial loop
and agent you can think
it of as a controller
or an orchestrator who knows what to do.
Based on its logic it will determine
when and how to call a model.
And model is the underlying intelligence.
These are the foundation
models which powers your agent
and generate the responses
based on the data that
they were trained on.
Next we have,
but sometimes model
cannot answer the direct,
cannot answer you directly.
For example, if I ask model,
give me the 10 recent Jira tickets
or Jira tickets for this project.
Model doesn't have the access
to that kind of information.
And that's why we have tools.
And tools are the external
entities that allows your agent
to talk to outside world other than model
to perform tasks like web
searches, database lookups,
code execution, calling APIs,
anything that your agent wants to do
for the task completion.
In fact, the agent can create
a new prompt internally
that goes through the same loop again.
And this is the...
This process of acting,
interpreting, planning
is what we call as agentic loop,
and it continues until the
task or the ask is completed.
The framework which we are gonna use today
to build the agent is Strands SDK,
and to define Strands,
it is an open source Python SDK,
which will let you build the AI agent
with just few lines of code.
What that means is
compared to other frameworks
where developers are required
to create the complex
workflows for their agents,
Strands Agent follows the model agnostic
or model driven approach,
the similar thing which
we saw in agentic loop.
So what happens is a
Strands can run on any infrastructure
and it can call a model
that are either hosted on Amazon Bedrock
or even open AI model.
So to clear quickly,
summarize this one.
Strands will let you define
how your agent can think
and act on his own.
But the next question is,
how can you make or make this agent
run in a scalable and
production way great?
The answer is use AgentCore.
So the AgentCore is a managed runtime
and infrastructure offering from AWS,
which will let you build, develop,
and operate your AI agent at scale.
It provides a lot of
out of box components,
which you can,
some of them you can see it on the screen.
And if you are hearing about AgentCore
or listening about the
AgentCore for the first time,
do not worry about it.
I will go on very high
level about the components
so that it is easy to follow.
So we have an agent who can think and act,
but it needs a runtime
which will basically
allows to fulfill the
business goals we have.
For example, multiple users access,
autoscaling, sandboxing sessions,
interacting with the tools
which we will have in the agent,
and most importantly the performance.
For everything like that,
you will need an AgentCore.
You can think of Strands
as providing the
intelligence to your agents
and AgentCore will provide the structure,
the scalability, the security
that your agent needs.
On top of that, if I want my agent
to remember the
conversation I had in past,
I could use memory in capability,
which will store the context information
across the session and the agents.
Along with memory and the runtime
AgentCore does have built in tool support.
And in AWS it provides
the native integrations
so that your agents can either
store your data in S3 buckets
or trigger a Lambda function
or even write into DynamoDB databases.
Other than native integrations,
you can also register
your APIs as MCP tools,
so that your agent can
access them securely.
So there is more,
you can see on top.
It's gateways.
AgentCore gateways will allow you
to expose your internal APIs
and Lambda functions if
you have any, as MCP tools.
And finally, we have identity
which will give you plenty
of options for authentication
and authorization to basically
lock down everything.
So we have seen Strands
or you just heard me about Strands
which will define the agent capabilities
and you will run it on AgentCore run time
for the scalability it requires.
So what is missing in these two?
So the answer,
before the answering it,
let me ask you
how do you think that the context,
the memory or the tooling information
or any other thing is flowing
reliably between the agent
and the system it needs to interact with?
That missing link is MCP.
So MCP is the open
standard which will let you
define how your agents can connect
or communicate with the
applications and the services.
It provides a consistent way
to expose the capabilities.
And what I mean is like your
database queries or APIs
or any other services as tools
so that your agent can
access them securely.
Additionally, MCP doesn't just expose
the capabilities as tool,
but it also provides three key
capabilities for your agent.
And first off that one is tools,
and these are the actions
that your agent can perform.
Essentially you are telling your agent,
this is what you can do.
For example, you can fetch the weather
or trigger a workflow
or even retrieve the customer data.
Second, we have prompts
and these are the data,
external data sources that
your agent can access,
like database, list,
documents, files, URLs,
basically all the information
that your agent can read.
And lastly, we have prompts
which is a instruction manual
including text and arguments.
So it is basically telling the model
that this is the given context
for the response you will send.
Okay, so to conclude everything.
Once again we have Strands
that will let you define
the agent capabilities.
AgentCore will allow you to
run in a scalable manner,
and MCP will expose the
capabilities as a tool
so that your agent can access them.
Altogether you will build an AI agent
into the existing legacy application.
So we have the scene now,
we know we have gone through the concept.
Now I'll ask my colleague Franz,
who will demonstrate to
you how to create an agent
using Strands SDK and run
it on agentic runtime,
all in an empty project.
Over to you Franz.
- [Franz] Thank you, Deepali.
Let me switch over to the other screen.
And hello, everyone,
Franz is my name.
So next to Jan we will try to
for the remaining 50 minutes
to do some coding stuff.
So as we started with the preparation
for this code talk today,
we had initially much more slides,
but that's a code talk.
So we are not here for
going through a lot of concepts
and then theoretical aspects.
But we had to set the scene
to give an understanding
that we want to use and
to build an agent today
with the Strands, Strands
Agents is the key,
transform it to a Bedrock AgentCore Agent
deployed then to the cloud
and then adding some capabilities.
So we will start a little bit low level,
but the level will increase.
Yeah, the second step we had
then to take a trade off.
Do we want to code
everything from scratch,
would not fit within the time.
So we will have some parts now
that we want to go through.
So we will also cope with some code
and then trying to give an understanding.
Feel free to ask questions as well.
We are here after the session
as well in case of questions,
but it's encouraged to
ask questions in between.
I hope you apologize if I sit down,
but it makes it much more easier
than to start with decoding,
and to give an understanding
what we wanna start with first.
I think you can see the screen,
just let me try to make this
a little bit more readable.
- [Deepali] Franz.
Yeah.
- Yeah, that was
my question (faintly speaking)
- [Deepali] Okay.
- Is this good?
- Yes.
(Franz laughs)
- [Franz] So what we are gonna start with,
as you can see or maybe not see,
this will be primarily
based on Python today.
So we will use Python
as this is the main
supported language as of now
to get started.
There are other options
how to use other languages.
I will come to that in a second.
But the first thing I want to go through
is to make use of these free packages.
So I have defined these free packages
in my requirements, TXT file,
and those packages are all we need
to transform the agent that
we're gonna start now with,
to deploy it and also to
AWS and intend to extend it.
So let me increase this here a bit.
So in addition,
what I'm going to do now is
also to create a virtual environment.
So next thing I'm going to do is to import
the packages
and as these packages
are getting imported,
I need to create a file
so that I'm able to,
that's my main file for the agent itself.
Reinventdemoagentmam345 for instance.
So what is now needed to
start with a Strands Agent,
it's pretty easy and straightforward.
First what we want to go do is to import
the agent class from the Strands package.
So as you can see there,
there is a class from the Strands package
that is needed that we
need to instantiate,
which is receiving user input,
processing the input
and so on and so forth.
So that's the first thing
we need to start with
when taking care of
building our first agent
or our initial agent,
and then the remaining free lines
to say that we have now
built the first agent
are those ones.
So what we are going to do is
now to instantiate the class.
The second thing here is to take an input.
So usually we are used
to take an input from a user interface.
We have also a user interface
that I will show you in a second.
But in that case
we are taking the user
interface from the CLI.
So in Python, that's input.
Yeah, give my name,
and I give myself a name
and then passing the
user input to the agent.
And that's pretty much it to get started.
So where I'm going back to my CLI,
just started.
And can now ask a question like
what is the capital of the USA?
So based on that question,
that's something the LMS are trained on.
So that's nothing very sophisticated.
So we will get immediately a response.
But if I would ask now something
as mentioned by my
colleague Deepali before
that requires some real
time information like
what is the weather today in
Las Vegas?
I would expect that the
LLM cannot return it back.
And as you can see here,
the LLM is not trained on
real time data as we know.
So this is something now
where we need to introduce
that was mentioned by my colleague before
making use of tools.
So these tools,
either you can write as
part of your agent itself
or you can use an SDK that has
already some tools included.
That's what we are going to do now
or making use of MCP,
which we will see then later on
by getting some tools returned.
So primarily when talking
to agents question is
what can you do for me?
And I will get in response some tools
that give you some
understanding so that the loop
between the agent and
the LLM is about tools
and their reasoning so that it can say,
okay, I found a tool that
might fit the prompt,
I will make use of it.
So this means we need to
add something in addition,
which is now the second
package that we imported,
we want to make use of,
which is coming from the
Strands tool package.
So what I'm trying to import here
is a tool that already exists
as part of the Strands package.
And you can see here a bunch of tools
that we can make use of.
We have here,
we know that the LMS are not
that great on doing mathematical stuff.
So we have a calculator tool,
we have also an RSS tool.
So we can use that tool imported.
So to get back...
Give me the 10 most recent
blog posts on the AWS channel
in that category, for instance.
HTTP request itself is more
generic but very helpful
because it has the capability to get
outside to the internet,
invokes some other APIs
and give us something in return.
And that's what we want to make use of.
So something we need just
to add on top of that is,
or what I want to make
use of is a system prompt.
System prompt primarily is like a persona.
I want to set some guard
rails or some pathways
and maybe also some boundaries
so that it is easier to get further.
So in that case I'm asking,
and giving as prompt that
it should only use APIs
that are not requiring any
kind of authentication,
API keys authorization, et cetera.
Usually we want to do that
for sake of simplicity.
We are trying to get access
to some external endpoints
that are not requiring that.
And the last remaining part
that we need to take care of
is to pass the system prompt
to the agent.
And in addition,
we also need to pass
the tool.
In that case we only make use of one tool,
we can have more tools
that we can make use of.
In that case we are
passing the system prompt
and the tool to our agent.
So let's try it again.
If there is a change compared
to the initial question that we have seen.
So again calling my agent.
So what is the weather today in Las Vegas?
And as you can see here already
it found a tool that it
wants to make use of.
I'm not debugging all information.
We can take a look into that in a second.
And what it tries now to
do is to find some APIs
with help of this agentic loop routing
and to go somewhere to find now
the recent information about the weather.
And it found something as we got in return
something that seems very reliable
and is a difference compared
to what we have seen before.
So we extended now our agent with tools.
The next step is as we have seen,
we have three packages
we want to make use of.
So we use the first one as the base one
for creating an agent,
the tools agents package for
making use of existing tools.
And the third one is the
Bedrock AgentCore package.
So that we can transform this
to a Bedrock AgentCore agent
and being able to deploy
it into the cloud.
So what is needed to...
There's not much needed
to to transform this one,
but what a surprise, we
need to import another
class which is coming from
the Bedrock AgentCore package.
So we need to have an,
we need to instantiate the
class Bedrock AgentCore rep
which we will do here.
And by doing this,
so what is it taking care of?
If you are instantiating this one,
it's creating an HTTP server
listening on port 8080.
And it has two endpoints
that are important
for an Bedrock AgentCore agent
there is a ping endpoint.
So kind of a health endpoint
especially also interesting
for multi-agent communication.
And the most important one
is the invocations endpoint
because the invocations
endpoint is the one
that is taking the prompt,
listening to the input.
So the JSON file in most cases.
And then to proceed with the first of.
We will see this in a second
how this is gonna work.
And in addition,
some minor changes that
we need to take care of.
So we need to also have a decorator
being part of the agent.
This is mandatory for any AgentCore agent
to have an entry point.
So we have this decorator app entry point
and then a function that has the payload
that we pass through.
It's trying to find in the JSON
attribute for prompt.
We are passing the user input.
So it's primarily the
same that we did here
but no longer from the CLI
but passing it then as a JSON,
and then returning it back.
And last remaining point
we need to take care of is
to add this here to make the app running.
So that's pretty much it.
Let's see how this is gonna work.
And the first thing you can see here,
your agent is live,
and it's blinking.
That's because now we have
an HTTP server listening
on port 8080 and waiting for
requests coming from a client.
So what I will do is to
switch over to a second tab,
and now I could use a postman
or something that is integrated in the IDE
or I can use curl,
which I'm going to make use of here.
So I'm having here a curl command
and trying to ask a question.
So like what is the
weather today in New York?
So this is gonna,
this is getting passed
to the running agent,
list in port 8080.
You can already see that
it is trying to make use
of the tool that is passed through.
And here we are waiting for the response.
This agentic loop introduced
on the slides at the beginning,
this iteration.
This can take once,
this can take multiple times.
So what I've seen also were questions like
I'm using Lambda,
can I now use instead AgentCore?
Probably most cases not depends
on what the use case is,
usually to transform something.
But you should not forget
this kind of loop might
take a couple of seconds,
especially in that case as
we are trying to find an API,
we are not aware of because
this is decision taken
by the LLM and the cycle
between the agent and the LLM.
In that case, you can see already
that this took more than one iteration.
You can see that there was
at least a second invocation
but in return, we got them something
that already makes sense,
and this is the response
that we got back from the (indistinct).
There's a question if we.
- [Attendee] Can you get a
screening response from a get call?
- Yes.
- Simple answer yes.
- [Franz] In a minute. (laughs)
But good question.
Great.
So still we are running locally.
That's not what we want to do.
But yeah,
usually when we start developing,
it's locally.
The next step we're
gonna want to achieve is
how to deploy it to the cloud.
As mentioned before by my colleague,
we have this serverless runtime,
AgentCore runtime
where we can run our agents in
and the next step is now to deploy it.
There are multiple ways
how to achieve that.
So you could use a for prompt environment,
you would use infrastructure as code,
CloudFormation, Terraform, et cetera.
Something that exists
when making use especially
or using Python is a toolkit
that I haven't introduced so far.
So because this becomes very handy,
it gives you some possibilities
with help of the AgentCore CLI to deploy
and to configure some stuff.
When you are doing this
with infrastructure as code,
you need to pass some attributes
and some configuration items.
And this is something we we will see here
in a second by making
use of another package.
And I'm trying to install this now.
This is called,
and this is not mentioned
in the requirements TXT
because I just want to
make use of it in the IDE.
Bedrock AgentCore starter toolkit.
And as is this is getting downloaded,
I can now just say configure,
AgentCore configure
and pass through my agent class.
So it's now going to ask me some questions
that are mandatory and
important to mention
or you need to consider when you are using
CloudFormation or Terraform.
First question is what
should we name the agent?
If you don't pass a name,
it'll take the file name.
We are good with that.
And taking this as standard.
Do you have a requirements TXT file?
Is it named the requirements TXT?
Yes. We are good.
What kind of deployment configuration
you want to make use of?
So Bedrock AgentCore is
GE for a couple of weeks,
a few weeks,
started with container
or Docker deployment.
Now it's even more easier,
very comparable to how
you would deploy Lambdas.
So you can use the first one,
which is not a default one.
It would then sip all the
assets needed together,
uploaded to S3 and behind all the magic
is going to get deployed to runtime.
Why you should then consider
Docker as a second option,
especially in that case if you have
specific requirements dependencies
that you want to adjust
in your Dockerfile?
But also one question might be,
okay, Python is good,
it's fully supported.
What about Java, Go or other languages?
So you could theoretically make
use of these other languages
as well
as long they're not fully supported
as Python in that case,
by building then a wrapper
so that you have these
endpoints that are mandatory,
the invocation endpoint
and the ping endpoint,
that's where you would probably then
also make use of Docker.
So we are good with the default option,
which is the number one,
which Python and environment
we want to make use of.
And yeah, execution role,
very comparable to Lambda.
You have a role that has
the necessary policies,
actions needed to run the
agent in your environment.
If you don't have one,
we are good to go with the default one.
So it'll take care of this as well.
As free bucket, where to upload it?
I don't have one,
I'm good to let one create it.
Authorization configuration.
So you can use OAuth,
or in that case I'm good
with IAM authorization.
Take this one.
You can also define some request headers,
especially if you have
multi-agent collaboration.
Very handy.
We are good to ignore that as well.
And last but not least,
we have memory.
Was mentioned in the slides
at the beginning as well.
If we are passing and
having the communication
in the user interface,
we don't want to have,
we have the context existing.
We don't want to pass 50,
100 lines of information.
We want to memorize it.
That's where we have short term
and long term memory that you
can make use of here as well.
We will come to that in a minute.
I'm good to skip this.
And that's primarily it.
So what is happening now in addition
is-
- We have not skipped it yet.
- [Franz] I have not skipped it.
Yeah, sorry, thanks.
Yeah.
And one of the advantages is
if you're using this data toolkit,
it gives you immediately also some
best practices how to proceed.
So AgentCore launch would be the command
to deploy the agent,
which would be now the next step.
And in addition what also happened is
it's creating YAML file locally,
based on what you have passed through
and for further communication
with this startup toolkit,
it will reference to this one.
So I will skip this.
What we want to do now is to
invoke AgentCore launch.
And it'll show you now
what is happening next.
So it's packaging all assets needed,
all imports that were considered
in the requirements TXT file
and it's creating now the zip file,
uploading it to S3,
creating the execution role
and deploying it to the runtime.
And to showcase you this in the console,
it is gonna look like this.
Let me increase this a little bit.
So you have this AgentCore service
which you wanna start.
You have then here some
of these capabilities
that we introduced at the beginning,
and let's start with runtime.
And you can then see here
immediately all the agents
that you have deployed
and running in your account,
in your region.
So in that case I'm in US East one,
North Virginia,
and I have here already my running agent.
So if I'm switching back,
I also have here
response in a positive way.
You will get also here immediately
a possibility to tail
on your CloudWatch logs.
So in case something happens,
observability is a very important
aspect also of AgentCore.
So open telemetry is fully supported.
We have all the traces
and spawns that we might
see also in a second.
And now we can invoke this from the CLI
or let me switch now to introduce you
to a user interface
which more or less is
listening all the agents
that you have deployed in your account.
And that's the one that we
have deployed a minute ago.
And I can now ask more
or less the same questions
as we have done before.
What is the capital of,
state something different, Germany?
And the initial invocation
of the agent may take one
or two seconds longer as it's starting
to spawn up
but will then remain in the session.
Yeah, and you can see in a very dirty way,
just adjacent output it's get getting us
something back from the LLM.
I can do now the same with something,
we have now seen three times.
So to not bother you with
something we have already seen,
I'm happy to switch over
to my colleague Jan.
- Yes.
- Who will try to make
use of the existing agent
and extend it with more capabilities
and also to attach it to the legacy app
without touching the legacy app.
- [Deepali] Yeah, go ahead.
- Sure.
- Before you deploy
the application to the cloud
in the second iteration,
why did it take reagent price
to get (faintly speaking)
- [Franz] You can debug
the whole cycle and what is going.
So the whole communication,
the cycle between agent and the LLM,
you can for sure trace this
for sake of simplicity.
I have skipped this now,
but you would then see it could be
because it did not found the API
or it found an API that was not able
to respond in a given time.
You will get all this information out
as part of your debug information.
In that case it was not
disclosed in this demo,
but usually there are reasons why API is
taking too much time.
It's not responding.
I'm not getting it in expect manner.
Everything is disclosed in
the output as you define
in your debug configuration.
But fair question,
especially for HTTP requests,
this may take longer
because it's kind of a
black box where it goes.
If you then use something that
you have more control over,
which you will see now in a second,
it usually it's much faster
because we have the
expectation on endpoints
we want take care of.
Jan will introduce you to that.
- [Jan] Yeah, also to add on this one,
adding a general tool like
HTTP request means the LLM
is like tempted to use
it for everything, right?
It might know what the
capital of Germany is
but it might ask an HTTP endpoint
nonetheless to validate
if it's really true.
So these general tools might tempt the LLM
to do stuff which we don't want to do.
Okay, looking at your faces,
you want to see some
Legacy Applications, right?
You're missing it already.
So we do have a Legacy Application,
and I have no idea what it is doing,
of course, I have.
But let's assume we just
got this on the table
and we have to add some
agentic AI stuff to it, okay.
So it's running on ECS,
it's some Java application,
it's using some database.
Let's check it out what it is doing,
and I heard you all love unicorns.
So the great part is it's a unicorn store,
and we can shop unicorns.
That's great.
So let's go ahead
and add an agentic
capability for our users
to not only use this website,
which is well quite old
but also use an agent
to shop unicorns, okay?
For this, we have the first issue here.
I don't know the endpoints
the application provides,
I have no idea which rest
endpoints are available.
So my first idea would be
let's use Amazon Q Developer
and ask it to create an
open API specification
out of my application, right?
That's quite simple.
I don't know what's going
on inside the application
but let's use Q Developer
to figure it out.
So please create an open API
spec out of my Legacy Application.
Please ignore text plain endpoints
because we don't want these.
Okay, so while Q developer is not working,
I will show you the result in a second
but I prepared the result already.
And I will pick this up to to use.
So we do have an open API spec,
and I swear this has been
generated by Q developer.
We will just pick this open API spec,
and we will go and switch over
into the AgentCore console
into the gateway.
So the gateway has been introduced,
it's a way to host tools basically.
And we have provisioned
one gateway already
and you can add several
targets to a gateway.
Targets can be,
and we will see that in a second.
Targets can be MCP servers, right?
So which you find on any open
source GitHub, for example.
It can be a lambda function
and it can be REST APIs.
So we can go ahead and say REST API
open API schema
and inline schema.
That's great.
We are just pasting the whole API schema
that has been generated
by Q Developer in here.
For authorization,
We are selecting an API key,
which we don't need.
Our application is accessible
from the public internet,
but in case you could also
configure OAuth or an API key.
I will add this as a target to my gateway.
That's great.
So now we have a second target,
we will get to the lambda target later on.
But now this gateway is able to interact
with our application
using the open API schema.
So what we have to do next is
we have to update our agent
to make use of this gateway, right?
That's the next step.
To show you what we are going to do.
I will quickly switch
over to this architecture.
You can see the Legacy
Application part, right?
And we are going to add the gateway.
We are going to use our
agent on the left side.
We are using the front end
that you have seen already,
and yeah, we will...
The goal is that our client,
our agent is using the gateway
and then the open API specification
to invoke endpoints in
our Legacy Application.
So we are not touching the
Legacy Application in any way.
We are really enhancing it.
- [Franz] Just to add a sentence,
'cause I had a recently a
conversation with a customer
who had the same challenge.
They have Legacy Application,
there is an open API schema
that you can write or
exist or generate with AI,
and the question was, okay,
but where do I need to write the code?
You don't need to write the code,
the translation.
That's where the gateway comes in,
and makes it so super easy
is the open API schema
that translates then
all the paths into tools
that you can run and
invoke from your agents.
So you don't need to
touch your Legacy App,
you don't need to write a code,
you're writing a code to
connect to the gateway
which can has multiple targets
but you can communicate
without making any changes,
writing any code
to make use of your Legacy Application.
- [Jan] Okay.
Then we are going back to the IDE,
I have great news.
Q developer was able to create
this open API specification file,
I will show you.
So he was able to create it,
we could have used it
but I wanted to speed up things, right?
So what we are going to do now is we have
to enhance our agent like Franz said,
we have to add the capability
for the agent to invoke the gateway,
which means fetching some credentials
and configuring the gateway.
I will guide you through it.
I will copy stuff,
stuff over to make it more quick.
But we will get there.
So the first thing we have to do is,
can you increase the size a bit?
The size to increase it in general?
- [Franz] Yeah, yeah, I will increase it.
Sure.
- Thanks.
So what we are going to do is
we are adding some more
imports at this point.
I will guide you through it.
I'm setting up the logging
because I want to be able to
see what the agent is doing
and as I mentioned we do have to get
some power meters or some secrets, right?
We have to authenticate
towards the gateway
and we also have to get the gateway URL.
So what I'm doing here is
I'm defining some variables
which is the gateway URL.
So this is the address where
our gateway is reachable.
I'm defining the memory,
we will get there later on.
And I'm also defining the
AgentCore gateway OAuth provider URL.
This is used to get an
access token, right?
So the agent is calling the auth provider
getting an access token
and with this access token
he's allowed to access the gateway.
I'm defining a model ID as well
and a system formed
which is a bit different saying
you are an agent which is
helping with shopping unicorns.
So that's it.
That's it for now.
We are getting the parameters.
Next step,
what we have to do is we have
to get this access token.
And the great thing is
in this Strands SDK,
there's a decorator requires access token.
We are just passing in
the OAuth provider URL
and we are getting back an access token,
that's quite nice.
Now we have to change the agent
initialization a little bit.
When we are talking about
tool usage and gateway usage.
We have to take care of
several user sessions, right?
So users do have sessions with an agent
and we have to handle that internally
to make sure that a tool is bound
to the session context of a user.
For this we will just add
the init agent method,
and yes, that's a bigger one.
But I will guide you
through it what it is doing.
So in this in init agent,
we are trying to get the
agent from the context.
All the context stuff
that you're seeing here
is completely related
to session management.
So it's all about separating user sessions
and getting an agent
for this user session.
If we already have an agent that's great,
we just return it because
it has been initialized
for this user session already.
If not, we want to initialize it.
Get the gateway access token, right?
As I mentioned,
you need to authenticate
towards the AgentCore gateway.
We are doing this using
the method we just created,
which is getting the access token.
Then some sanity tracks.
That's fine.
And the next step is we
are creating an MCPClient.
So our agent is now,
will now use MCP to
communicate with the gateway
And the MCPClient takes our gateway URL
and the gateway access token.
And we are doing some timeout, right?
So two minutes timeout for a call,
that's fine for our demo.
So afterwards we do
have the gateway client,
we have to start it, right?
We are starting it
and then we save it in the session,
that's happening here.
So for the next week
where the user does the
session is already started
and we will just pick
up the existing agent
including the sessions.
We are creating the model.
We are selecting a specific
model in this case,
and then we are initializing
the agent like we did before.
We are passing in the model
and we are passing in the gateway tools.
And I was jumping over this one,
this is quite important.
After initializing the MCPClient,
we have to do,
fetch the tools which
are available, right?
Our agent is wanting in one time
and the gateway is wanting somewhere else
and the agent has to
fetch the available tools
from the gateway to inject
it into the prompt, right?
For the LLM to be able to make a decision
and that's what happening here.
So on the gateway client
we are invoking the
list towards sync method
and we are retrieving all
the tools meaning targets,
and for the open API specification target,
all the methods available.
So we are getting back the tools,
we are passing this to the agent,
stowing the agent in the context
so we don't have to do it
again in the next session.
And we are nearly done,
just a small step left,
which is the lifespan manager.
So you can see that we have been using
the Bedrock AgentCore app before
but now we are passing in the lifespan.
That's also completely
related to session management.
I will not go too deeply into it,
but basically it's tying the agent
and the gateway client
towards this session
and Bedrock AgentCore,
the SDK extension is taking care of this.
Great.
Then we are nearly done.
I just want to make it a
little bit more beautiful.
And there was a question about streaming.
We are doing that now.
So the agent invocation.
The agent invocation,
let me go over, there we go.
So as you have seen in the user interface,
we were returning the JSON,
and that was not really user friendly.
If we want to offer an end user experience
for shopping unicorns,
we have to do some parsing.
So I'm invoking the agent async here.
And I'm then parsing the results
and just returning the wheel checks.
Also the other things,
I'm just doing some sanity checks
to check if we do have a session ID,
if we do have a user message.
So a prompt coming in
and then I'm initializing the agent
and invoking it,
that's all what we had to change.
And this is a one time,
one time change that you have to do.
Now it's as easy like Franz mentioned,
it's as easy as adding a
second target to the gateway
and the agent will
automatically pick it up.
So let's see how that works
by updating our agent.
I will just do an AgentCore launch
like we have seen before.
I've configured this stuff.
So I have a YAML file here
and we will now update the agent
and see if we can get some information out
of our Legacy Application.
- [Franz] You want to
switch to the console?
- [Jan] I mean yeah, we can
quickly go to the console
and take a look.
So we do have one time here.
This is the session name agent
and it has been last updated at 12:18.
Yeah, that's exactly what happened.
So let's switch over to the browser
and take a look into our front end.
I will just reload this one,
and we are creating a shopping session.
So these are the sessions.
Shopping session is the session ID
that's getting passed
to the agent one time
and based on the session ID,
it will initialize an agent.
Okay, which unicorns
do we have in store?
Let's see.
So the first request as Franz mentioned,
the one time has to spin up
and the agent is being initialized,
including fetching the excess token,
fetching the tools from the gateway.
So the first request is taking some time,
but afterwards the
requests are quite fast.
Okay,
that's quite nice.
So we get an answer that we have
three types of magical unicorn products,
a unicorn float,
a unicorn party dress,
and unicorn HipHop.
That's great.
So based on the open API spec,
the agent was now able to
figure out the user's intention
and giving me the products.
And I would like to shop a unicorn.
So I would like to go ahead
and say let's buy a
party dress, for example.
But for this to work,
we have to create a user account,
and the agent has to remember
which unicorn I want to shop.
So we will use,
and make use of the memory now
because memory allows the agent
to retrieve previous
messages that I have sent
and that he answered,
and I promise compared
to what we did before,
it's a really small change.
So let me quickly switch over.
The memory one is really quite easy.
So we are going back into the IDE.
There we go.
And when we are initializing
the agent right here,
we are just adding
the AgentCore memory configuration.
So we are passing in the session ID,
I've shown you in the user interface,
we can create a new session,
and of course, we want to the memory
to be separated between sessions, right?
I don't want user A to retrieve
information from user B.
And we could add the actor ID,
not doing that today,
but we will separate on the session ID.
And next step is now that we
have the AgentCore config,
we are creating a session manager, right?
And in this case it's an
AgentCoreMemorySessionManager,
and we are just passing
this one over to the agent.
So that's the whole thing.
The memory has created by me before,
but as you have seen in
the CLI which ones used,
you could use this CLI to
create a memory for you.
So that's quite convenient.
Okay, change to the agent has been done.
Next step, we have to update the agent,
and oh, that's local.
AgentCore launch.
So it'll now just update the agent
and afterwards we are
going to shop unicorn.
Let's go back to the console
to check what's happening.
I can quickly show you the memory
that has been provisioned here.
So as you can see we do
have a memory available.
We can also see that events
expire after 30 days.
So nothing super interesting here.
But-
- [Franz] Not to forget
about the observability
to showcase this as well.
- [Jan] Yeah, yeah.
We can take a look at
observability in a second.
I quickly want to buy
one unicorn at least.
So the agent has been updated.
We will go back to our front end
and create a new session,
which is the MemoryShoppingSession.
Okay.
I want to buy a unicorn.
Now I want to show the guided experience
that the agent will provide.
So I mean I was quite
unspecific in my intention,
or yeah, quite unspecific.
I expect the agent to deliver
the available unicorns to me
and then he will guide me
through account creation and stuff.
Yeah, that's great.
So he's offering me
the available unicorns.
I'm for a party dress, definitely.
Let's go with the party dress.
Okay.
The next question should be,
do you have an account,
or would you like me to create one?
Okay, I want to create an account.
It needs my name,
first name, last name,
and my email address,
which is this
345monday@amazon.
Okay, let's see.
He should figure out all the details
and in the background,
now this loop will take some time
because he will create an account.
And he will add the unicorn
to my basket in this account.
And this Legacy Application
has now checkout process to it.
But we will log into the application
and see that it really worked, right?
So account has been created,
and I do have a unicorn
party dress inside my basket.
That sounds fantastic.
Let's go to the store.
I'm going to log in.
The password is not being checked
so I'm just using in this case,
but we can see I'm logging in
and I do have one item in my cart.
So by just adding an open
API spec to the gateway,
the agent is now really able to interact
with my application,
which I have not touched in
any way for this example.
- [Franz] You could maybe show
in the open API the post method
that was used for that case.
- [Jan] Yeah, I would like to show you
some observability parts for the last-
- Yeah, yeah.
- One or two seconds.
Because adding all this
capabilities to the agent,
it might get quite hard to understand
what is happening, right?
And for this, we can enable tracing
on the agent one time on
the memory on the gateway.
And what this allows us to see is
a whole overview of
what is going on.
So we can have
application map.
So if we go into the
application map and expand that,
we can see our agent, right here.
That's the agent wanting
on AgentCore one time.
We can see that it is using
the Bedrock AgentCore
core service, of course.
We can see that it is using our gateway.
We can see that it's using the memory
and the OAuth, right?
We are getting an access token.
We can also see that
it is invoking Bedrock
and the LLM really,
and did eight request to the LLM.
And we can also see that we
are using Secrets Manager
to fetch the OAuth secret
and the gateway URL.
So we gather a wheel inside
into what's happening.
And the real cool thing is,
the gateway is invoking
our unknown remote service.
So we can see that the gateway
is invoking our application
and we do see that several
requests happen to this one.
And I think that's a
great way to really see
what the agent is doing
and also how many requests
to an LLM it's doing
in a great visual way.
- [Franz] To wrap this up,
these three QR codes,
especially the third one.
All those demos that exist
especially the third one is
a large GitHub repository
with a lot of tutorials.
The second one with a lot of use cases.
So they're ready to deploy
CloudFormation templates
that are primarily showcasing
that what we tried to
do now in 60 minutes.
We had some stretch tasks
that we wanted to show you today as well,
but with respect to the
time, not feasible and easy.
But really encourage you
to make use of GitHub repo.
Deepali, you want to wrap
up with the last one?
- [Deepali] No, I think you did it.
I hope you guys enjoyed
our cold walkthrough.
Hopefully you're taking
something back home
to try that out in your
personal environments
or company's environment.
So yeah, enjoy the rest of your day.
Thank you for attending
and please provide your feedback
if you loved our session.
Thank you.
- [Franz] In the moment, thanks.
- Thank you.
(attendees applauding)